let's think a little bit about limits of
piecewise functions that are defined
algebraically like our f of X right over
here pause this video and see if you can
figure out what these various limits
would be some of them are one-sided and
some of them are regular limits or
two-sided limits
alright let's start with this first one
the limit as X approaches 4 from values
larger than equaling 4 so that's that
what that Plus tells us and so when X is
greater than 4 our f of X is equal to
square root of x so as we are
approaching 4 from the right we are
really thinking about this part of the
function and so this is going to be
equal to the square root of 4 even
though right at 4 our f of X is equal to
this we are approaching from values
greater than 4 we're approaching from
the right so we would use this part of
our function definition and so this is
going to be equal to 2 now what about
our limit of f of X as we approach 4
from the left well then we would use
this part of our function definition and
so this is going to be equal to 4 plus 2
over 4 minus 1 which is equal to 6 over
3 which is equal to 2 and so if we want
to say what is the limit of f of X as X
approaches 4 well this is a good
scenario here because from both the left
and the right as we approach x equals 4
we are approaching the same value and we
know that in order for the 2 sided limit
to have a limit you have to be
approaching the same thing from the
right and the left and we are and so
this is going to be equal to 2 now
what's the limit as X approaches 2 of f
of X well as X approaches 2 we are going
to be completely in this scenario right
over here now interesting things do
happen at x equals 1 here our
denominator goes to 0 but at x equals 2
this part of the curve is going to be
continuous so we can just substitute the
value it's going to be 2 plus 2 over 2
minus 1 which is 4 over 1 which is equal
to 4 let's do another example so we have
another piecewise function
and so let's pause our video and figure
out these things all right now let's do
this together so what's the limit as X
approaches negative 1 from the right so
if we're approaching from the right when
we are greater than or equal to negative
1 we are in this part of our piecewise
function and so we would say this is
going to approach this is going to be 2
to the negative 1 power which is equal
to 1/2 what about if we're approaching
from the left well if we're approaching
from the left we're in this scenario
right over here where to the left of x
equals negative 1 and so this is going
to be equal to the sign because we're in
this case for our piecewise function of
negative 1 plus 1 which is a sine of 0
which is equal to 0 now what's the
two-sided limit as X approaches negative
1 of G of X well we're approaching two
different values as we approach from the
right and as we approach from the left
and if our one-sided limits aren't
approaching the same value well then
this limit does not exist
does not exist and what's the limit of G
of X as X approaches 0 from the right
well if we're talking about approaching
0 from the right we are going to be in
this case right over here 0 is
definitely in this interval and over
this interval this right over here is
going to be continuous and so we can
just substitute x equals 0 there so it's
going to be 2 to the 0 which is indeed
equal to 1 and we're done